do believe that women have more power
than we actually realize because even
back in the day like i'm reading um the
iliad right now and um a lot of wars
were started because of women
i think women realize it to be honest
lined up but i just feel like women
aren't realizing the amount of power
that they have
as you said there's a lot of crutches
that we have in society that are making
us feel like we have this power but i
feel like it's a bit on um
yeah
women know i think i think there's a
select i think there's just as we have a
upper select portion of men who might be
seen as pre-select or you know upper
echelon yeah yeah no i agree i feel like
there's a portion of men who maybe don't
relate to that top tier
who are well aware of the fact that a
lot of women are well aware of the power
that they hold i think some aren't
though i think you know ignorance is
bliss
i mean ignorance is bliss but i think
there's actual ignorance as well like
so what kind of power do you mean um
we have the power to
you know
inspire men
to carry ourselves in the way that
you know not all of them but will
encourage them to treat us in a
different way and i think if women band
together and actually started to maybe
carry ourselves in more of a modest way
i don't want to as i said i'm popular
opinion i'm probably going to have a lot
of that here but i feel like we start to
carry ourselves in a certain way then
you know
i don't want to say schooling guys but
just carrying ourselves in a certain way
well but i think the problem is after
birth control you can't go back because
there's always going to be a girl that
puts her tits out
to get to get something
like whether it's only fans whether it's
just being like the side chick whether
it's because the problem is after birth
control it gave us the ability to
basically girls that are fours fives and
sixes to sleep with the eights nines and
ten so everyone's screwing the same
twenty ten fifteen percent of guys
and the issue is like after birth
control like you can't go back
but i think that's i think we've just
entered a realm where women are given
more choice but i think they don't they
don't realize the power of the choices
that they make behind them because they
still we're because we because we've
been conditioned in such a way that
we're
most women not most men but some women
feel
they they feel fall into that category
feeling victimized well it's because
women like to be victims yeah and i
think that's and i think i think a lot
of people like to be victims because i
think most people don't like taking
responsibility for themselves but look
at it
like this but the thing is the thing is
men aren't bailed out women are always
bailed out of a bad decision they're
homeless there's women's shelters
there's no men's shelter there's not not
by and large
every every bad decision a woman makes
she's bailed out of in some way or
another
most of the time no a man it's not the
same
is it not no
definitely like the thing is the thing
is reality hits men hard so for example
if a girl gets fat right we have body
positivity there's no body positivity
for men they don't give a [ __ ] thank you
there's no like like and
and if um if a girl gets like sleeps
with a ton of people there's
slut-shaming and so like they take away
the things that men care about yeah but
they don't do that to women
like like even so if we if we get fat
we're bailed out of that decision
because there's body positivity if we
sleep around we're bailed out we're
bailed out of that decision so if we if
we decide to be [ __ ] we're bailed out
because there's birth control if that
fails we're bailed out because of
abortion if that fails and you keep the
kid and you're homeless you're bailed
out because there's women in children's
centers if if that doesn't work there's
some government program and here i'm not
sure what it is but there's always some
government program paying out single
mothers so it's like whatever we do
we're bailed out you know who has that
and and you know he has that many
bailouts or that many um back doors that
they can actually go through do you know
the only other group of people that have
that many back doors children oh
true just saying yeah question
do you think women have too many choices
yeah do you think two main choices is a
bad thing i think that we all have
choices that we are
unaware of um
but do you think too many choices is
actually a bad thing because i actually
agree even for but this is not just for
women this is foreign we don't
understand that there's consequences
right
well that's the whole thing about the
whole baby daddy baby mama culture like
that whole oh what are the consequences
of me doing this i've always said to
people
anyone can have sex with any anyone they
want to i'm not going to tell people not
to have sex but have it in a way where
you're not creating a generation of
children right that are going to be
you know and the narrative is that
there's a bunch of deadbeat dads that
aren't taking care of their kids and
that oh she just got finessed or she
just you know fell in love like and even
even when i i bring like baby mothers on
here it's always the guy it's never
anything with them or i picked wrong
there's no accountability for their
actions it's always i picked wrong
therefore putting it on the guy yeah and
i'd like to hear i said i'd like to hear
the guy's version yeah there's a lot
because baby mothers say a lot they say
oh my baby daddy is this he's that and
i'm toxic yeah i wonder what the guys
would be saying about you know i mean
like what would guys like how would they
talk to talk about you as a co-parent
how would they talk about you as as a
partner in general do you know i mean we
don't get to hear that narrative so it's
like okay cool one of the reasons
probably why kevin samuel said you don't
get any hard on your baby daddy because
that you know what you picked him like
it's what you've done and so can i just
say sierra yep
i was about to say hello
i have a question do you look like
sierra do you look like sierra do i look
like sierra i don't look like like
no i'm saying i'm saying like this is
this is this is a girl that's a nine
and then
i was right about to say before
everybody said this i was about to say
people lot people love because it's
relatable to go to the famous examples
yeah but i just want to say even though
you've just said it my point was going
to be people go to the high-end
relatable examples of this but what do
they mean they're they're they're really
they're not average jane thompson but we
can see them though so yeah we'll
probably go to that average james come
average james feel like it's a relatable
example why is it relatable you know
what going back to what the lady was
saying before in the green dress i feel
what she's saying because you know
really even
just never yes
i feel what she's saying because even
though she has got two children etc etc
the way she carries herself a man could
fall in love with her really yes yeah
but i think like how can you possibly
see him no but understand something
but that's like women are emotional so
you're looking at this from a girl's
point of view because you're thinking
like oh if i met a guy and he just
charmed me the right way like i could
fall in love and like a lot of girls do
like they'll say oh i'll never date that
that and that and then their next
boyfriend is that like men are more
logical it's like a costs and a minuses
[ __ ] okay like so she looks she can look
great i mean people like all right fall
in love with her but he knows at the end
of the day he's going to be taken on her
two boys yeah so
now he's got a way up okay cool i might
love her but
i'm gonna be one taking over our
household two going into a household
with two boys who know i'm not their
father yeah like you know i mean like
all of these stuff has got a way up so
it's like
yeah
you know you can have two children and
look good but like i said on the
quote-unquote dating market
are guys looking for you and she would
rather by the way
she clearly what i took from earlier on
is clearly that was somebody who would
rather be with nobody yeah than be with
anybody who it was felt like wasn't on
her plateau yeah so that's fine
but then the conundrum again is the man
name who you view on your plateau one
what exactly from you and then the men
and then the men who
and then the men who made because you
see one thing people don't necessarily
talk about is the fact that you know
what
when men say that the sort of men who
would step into a pre-made family and
some men say that you know that's a
that's a little weaker than than the man
who
who is not doing that i would say any
man that does that to be a stepdad
actually i think do you think he's
stronger than i think i